Good, ooh, yeah there we go. Good morning,
John.
I just wanted to take you down to the Clark
Fork River, which is close to flooding right
now.
John, I want to start this video by asking
you a question. What were you thinking...when
you gave yourself a punishment? Because that,
wow, now you have two because of the Helen
Hunt thing.
Yeah, I just spat in the river! I'm phlegmy!
There's a walking path right up here. Probably
people wondering why there's a guy down here
screaming. But you know, it's downtown; there's
crazy people all over the place!
What was that noise? That was a crazy noise.
Whoa. Oh, it was, it was the ice cream truck.
It's playing "Sexy Back". Ice cream trucks
have apparently grown up a little since I
was a kid.
So here's something that I think no one knows.
Uhh, baby boys used to be dressed in pink
until the 1940s, and baby girls were dressed
in blue. It was totally flip-flopped! Until
Hitler put little pink triangles on gay people
during World War II because he wanted to label
them so that everyone could take the "proper
precautions", and you know, so that he could
later kill them more efficiently. And after
that, pink became an effeminate colour. Because
of Hitler! The entire world switched! And
that is why pink ribbons are for boobies.
Because of Hitler.
Vlogbrothers: we teach you things that you
don't know.
I'm bringin' sexy back! Yeah! Pah-pah-pah!
Yeah!
Don't believe I'm on the side of a river?
Here's a stick. This is not a green screen,
people. I should throw a rock in the river
so you can see. Ugh! Yeah!
So John. Punishment idea. Corey Vidal once
made a video in which he, uh, annotated it,
and then he made people click, and then you
clicked on two items that he would then blend
and drink.
We obviously created the blending and drinking
of stuff, so I, uh, wrote to Corey, and I
asked him if I could appropriate that idea,
and he said, "Absolutely, that's just fine."
So instead of blending, Nerdfighters, you
are going to make John make a sandwich! There's
going to be six ingredients, and you are going
to be able to click on two of the ingredients.
He'll make a sandwich with those two things,
put them in between a piece of bread and then
eat them. Like sprinkles and bacon. Or pig's
feet and marshmallows. Or lard and lox! Lard
and Lox: the Steve Buscemi story. The newest,
hippest nightclub in downtown New York is
Lard and Lox. I don't know what I'm talking
about!
John, did you know that the tallest man in
the world once reached his giant arms down
the throat of a dolphin to remove shards of
plastic from the dolphin because no one else's
arms were long enough, and he was able to
do it, and the veterinarians couldn't do it,
only he could? Did you know that? I bet Shaq
could have done it. But Shaq was too busy
that day. He's not going to be so busy anymore.
Achilles heel? What kind of a bad-ass has
a bad Achill--wait a second. Achilles would
be a good example of that.
I found an ant! Come here, ant! Show yourself
to the video blog. The Nerdfighters want to
see you! Hello, ant. He's big. He's a big
ant. Can you see him? Can you see him? There
he is. That's enough of that.
So that is my idea for one of your punishments.
And it could be both of your punishments.
Your punishment has to be-- Here's two punishments.
One, you have to make a video that has more
than forty video parts, and that would be
if six...six times six is thirty-six, so maybe
more than thirty-five. And your other punishment
is to make a lot of sandwiches with gross
stuff in them.
Nerdfighters, leave suggestions in the comments
for things that should be included in, uh,
John's sandwich-making.
Also, I've been working tirelessly on my new
album, which I know it should have come out
a long time ago, and it has songs that have
been out for ages like 'Strange Charm' and
'What Would Captain Picard Do'? But it also
has new songs that you haven't heard yet like
'Shake A Booty' and 'My Phone'.
I'm very excited about it. It's called Ellen
Hardcastle, of course. And here is the cover
art that Alan Lastufka designed. Very excited!
Yes, 'Phineas Gage' is on this as well. I'm
hopefully going to have it available for LeakyCon.
If you're going to be at LeakyCon, I hopefully
should have the album there. And then it should
be on sale, uh, on DFTBA shortly after that,
which is, like, July 13th, I think?
So, I'm very excited about that. And John,
I'm very excited about watching you eat sandwiches.
John, I will see you on...blehhh. Friday.